la célébrité l'argent et la gloire ce
n'est pas donné à tout le monde
de plus cela peut à la longue devenir
dur à gérer perte de la notion de
réalité délire mégalomane décision
farfelue paranoïa tout ça tout ça
kanye west oui parce que je vous
explique on dit pas kanye west ont dit
kany west est un très bon exemple de ce
que la célébrité poussé à l'extrême peut
faire croire à un homme un homme certes
riche et célèbre mais qui n'a
certainement pas les épaules pour
supporter le poids de ses propres
ambitions
kanye west n'a jamais caché son amour
inconditionnel envers sa propre personne
il n'ya qu'à écouter ses chansons
je suis un dieu
je viens tout juste de on sent qu'il a
de l'ambition le matin et vu le degré de
narcissisme
on se doutait bien qu'ils allaient nous
sortir un truc du genre je vais me
présenter à l'élection présidentielle
quand il annonce sa candidature début
juillet les gens se disent ça se trouve
ça peut marcher
écoutons le peut-être qu'il a un
programme en plus il est soutenu par son
sulfureux camarades elon musk à qui il a
promis qu'il serait dans charge du
programme spatial américain après son
élection
donc tout ça a l'air sérieux son
programme
enfin plutôt ses idées il les étals dans
une interview donnée au rédacteur en
chef de forbes le 8 juillet dernier
on y apprend que son parti s'appelle le
buzz départ hâtif pourquoi parce que
lorsqu'il sera élu ce sera
l'anniversaire de tout le monde qu'il
est le candidat de dieu qu'il est sûr de
gagner puisque sa vie n'est qu'une
longue et immense victoire qu'il ne
soutient plus donald trump et ne porte
plus sa casquette rouge que le vote
démocrat chez la population noire relève
du suprématisme blanc qu'il
jamais voté de sa vie qu'il a eu le prix
19 en février que les vaccins sont la
marque de la bête et que lorsqu'il sera
élu il gérera les etats-unis comme le
pays fictif de wakanda dans le film
black panther ça part dans tous les sens
le mec a des idées sur tout mais il a
surtout des idées comme disait coluche à
ce premier meeting était exceptionnelle
[Applaudissements]
finalement qu'allié a fait un petit
séjour rapide en hôpital psychiatrique
histoire de soigner son anxiété et tout
le monde se demande aujourd'hui s'il va
pas finalement renoncé à se présenter
dans l'humiliation pour être sévère 2 %
dans les sondages et des électeurs noirs
qui n'ont pas vraiment envie d'être
représenté par un mégalo en train de
perdre les pédales trop d'ambition tu
l'ambition et rend ridicule le ridicule
ne tue pas ce qui ne tue pas rend plus
fort c'est pas mal ça
[Musique]